- This is the keynote I gave in Stockholm,
crushed the crowd because that's
just how I do in Stockholm.
They call it a syndrome.
What is the Stockholm syndrome?
- I literally said that to my mom today
and I don't even know
if I used it correctly.
- Can somebody Google it while I,
'cause I'm using this intro, anyway.
- Hey Siri, what is
the Stockholm syndrome?
- Oh voice baby, voice.
- [Siri] Stockholm syndrome
is a condition that causes
hostages to develop a
psychological alliance
with their captors as
a survival strategy--
- Cool.
You guys are my hostages.
- [Siri] You want to hear more?
(laughing)
- Yeah, I get it.
Stockholm syndrome (laughing),
wow that's cool.
Watch this keynote,
tell me what you think.
(upbeat rock music)
Hey Stockholm.
- [Audience Member] What's up?
- What's up?
Very excited to be here.
Want to talk about the one
thing that I'm positive
that we are all connected by.
I think one of the challenges
that I have as somebody
who likes to do speeches
is that I'm obsessed
with being consumer centric, right?
At the end of the day, I
think every success I have
comes far more from humility and listening
than it does from my big
mouth and all my talking
and things of that nature
and one of the keys
that I think a lot about when
I speak is getting a sense
of who's in the audience
and reverse engineering.
Obviously I can't give
the same speech to a room
full of 22 year old founders
that are trying to build
machine learning companies
as I can to a bunch
of 16 year olds who are
trading crypto currency
in the same way that I can't
to a 48 year old executive
Fortune 500 CMO crowd and so
I'm always kind of weaving.
I have a thesis.
It's very simple.
It's right there.
I day trade attention.
It is going to be the core
of what I want to talk
to you about because it's
the only thing that if you're
in here as an executive or B to B,
how many people here are in B to B?
The B to B space?
Raise your hands high.
Great.
B to C?
How many people here are entrepreneurs
and own their own business?
Raise your hand.
Great.
How many don't and they work somewhere?
50, 50, 50, 50.
Right?
So I think what's very scary
about that in my ambition
that everybody here
enjoys the talk is that
there's a lot of nuances and
practicalities that play out
very differently but the
one thing that 100% connects
every single person in
this room is the need
to get somebody's attention
before they tell them
how good their thing is.
Whether you're sitting
here and very altruistic
and are trying to raise
money for a non profit
or if you want to sell a bottle of wine,
it's all the same game,
which is very simply
where is the attention?
How do you then communicate in
that environment contextually
to the attention?
And then, can you create the
output that you're looking for?
I spend a lot of time in this.
I've spent a lot of time
in this my whole life.
When I was six years old and
moved to Edison, New Jersey,
for a lot of you that
don't know me, I was born
in the Soviet Union,
immigrated to the United States
when I was three, lived
a very humble life,
studio apartment, seven
family members, you know,
spent my first 18 years
taking one family vacation.
Basically after I was 11
or 12 years old had to buy
everything for myself.
Very, very fortunate, to be honest.
Taught me really how to get
mine and taught me a lot
of the things that have made me successful
but the interesting thing
was I was an entrepreneur
right from the beginning.
I'm 42 years old and in America,
good grades was the only
way somebody was judged
in the 80's and 90's and
I did not have good grades
and so for a long period of
my time I was not winning.
I was a losing player.
A lot of my friends'
parents looked down on me
because their kids got A's and I got F's
and I used to sit there are
look at them when they would
make fun of me, this is the
parents, not making fun of me
in a mean way, but they
would make slide comments
and I would sit there and
say, don't you realize
that your straight A kid is
gonna work for me one day.
(laughing)
It's so basic.
Anyway.
(audience laughing)
When I was seven years old
and started my first kind of
business, six, seven years
old, it was lemonade stands
which is very cliche in the United States,
but I took a very different approach.
I had four or five of
them because I commenced,
manipulated my friends to
stand behind them all day
in the summer and sell
lemonade and what I did
was I walked up and down
the streets of New Jersey
and I would sit and try
to figure out which tree
and which post and which
sign I could put my signs on
and I did that by literally
sitting on the ground
and watching cars drive
by for three to four hours
in the middle of the summer.
This is what came natural to me.
It came natural to me DNA
that I was trying to follow
your eyes while you were
driving and try to figure out
was it better to be put
here or here or up there
and that's basically been
the story of my life.
Today, today I do that.
I try to figure out when
are you gonna spend time
on Instagram or Snapchat
or Pinterest or LinkedIn.
How soon is it before you
all interact with an Alexa
or a Google Home device to
get information or buy things?
Where is your attention in
an altruistic, kind of future
world of AR and VR and what
is it about machine learning?
What are we doing?
Where are we going?
What happens to restaurants
with self driving cars
if we're gonna eat in there?
How can I story tell to
you when you're driving?
Today, I story tell to
you through voice, right,
because when you're driving, it's passive.
You can consume it.
How does that change?
Why is, while everybody's
obsessed with video consumption
I'm going and spending
all my time on audio
because I know, actually watch this.
This may be very
interesting for this crowd.
How many people here
are fans of my content
and consume my content
and don't raise your hand
because you're trying to
be nice, just if you do,
raise your hands.
Alright, first of all, that sucks.
(audience laughing)
(laughing)
Alright, one more time, hands up.
Great.
Of you, how many of you
in the last year or two
have started listening more to the podcast
and watching a little less of the video?
Raise your hands.
That, to me, is the
most interesting thing.
Thank you.
That, to me, is the most
interesting thing happening
right now which is, I think,
we're about to live through
the explosion of voice and
I'll get to that in a minute
but I want to go back because
there's so many people
in the B to B space.
What day trading attention
means is that everything
that you're gonna hear
coming out of my mouth
around voice, Instagram,
influencers, Facebook,
in this moment has the potential
to not matter tomorrow.
I doubt it because it usually
takes a little more time
but literally 15 months ago I made a video
saying that Instagram was
in trouble, that Snapchat
was growing very quickly
and starting to penetrate
30 year olds, that
Facebook was much bigger
than people realized at a younger age,
and that I did not see a
place for Instagram to play
as Snapchat started
winning that generation.
Literally a month later,
and I didn't know this,
they came out with all the
features that Snapchat has
and here we are 15 months
later but basically after
I made the video it was
literally 100 days later
that Instagram became the
most important platform
of attention and that's
why I call it day trading
where I used to call it,
if you came to a talk
five years ago that slide
would have said market
in the year that you live in, right?
My thesis is that most of you,
especially in the B to B space
are wasting an ungodly amount
of time and money and energy
on places where people
are not paying attention
because of history and tradition
and that's how you've always done it
and that you're underspending
where their attention
actually is and that's
where the arbitrage is,
that's the opportunity.
That is where I and people
that trade the way I do
make their wealth, build their businesses
but I had to change it
from marketing in the year
that you live in to day trading attention
because everything's happening so fast.
It's unbelievable to me
how big of a deal this is
and how quickly it's changing.
But here are some of the
frameworks I understand.
For everybody in this room,
if you do not produce content
and story tell on this
device, you are becoming
unbelievably irrelevant by the minute.
If you do not understand
how to take your brochure
or your booth at a trade
conference or your print ad
in a catalog and convert
it to being relevant
to on here, you are becoming
increasingly irrelevant.
The biggest mistake that
this room is gonna make
is they're gonna say things
like, but my 59 year old
target audience isn't living on there
and they will make grave
business mistakes over the next
three to four years based on
their romantic point of view
on technology instead of the reality
of what's actually happening.
My friends, I think in only practicality.
I was brought up in an
environment where eventually
after having a successful
baseball card business
that I was making three to
4,000 dollars a weekend in,
I was dragged into my dad's
liquor store and had to help
build that family business.
I built my dad's business
from a three to a 60 million
dollar business in a
very short period of time
on the back of making every
penny work like a dollar.
My dad's business was doing
3.7 million dollars in sales
on 10% gross profit, which
means we had $370,000
before expenses and I built
that business from that base
to 60 million in five
years with no MNA, no VCs,
because what I did was
I day trading attention.
In 1996 to 2001, that meant
two big bets that I made.
One was email.
How many people here
have done email marketing
in their careers?
Raise your hands.
Please raise them high,
I want to get a sense.
Great.
So you'll love this.
In 1996 I had an email newsletter
that had 91% open rates.
It had 91% open rates not
because it was so incredible
what I was writing in there.
I was writing, buy this wine, click here.
It was incredible because
nobody was doing email marketing
in 1996.
It was a new phenomenon.
How many people had email in 1998?
Raise your hands.
Great, so for the youngsters
you're about to learn something
because most of this
stuff you don't even know.
In 1998 youngsters, this
is how email happened.
Somebody would send an
email and us old folk
we would open and read
every single fucking email.
(audience laughing)
The supply and demand of attention.
It was a new medium and
all of us traded email
the way we traded mail,
you had to kind of properly
look at it.
We now no longer do that.
We now care so much about
our time that the reason
we don't unsubscribe from
newsletters that we don't read
anymore is because it
takes longer to unsubscribe
than it does to just delete.
It is time arbitrage.
It is attention and this is how we play.
The second bet I made
happened a little bit later.
When I started winelibrary.com
Google didn't exist
so it's just fascinating to think about
very much the themes of the
gentleman right before me
about how early this is,
how much we don't know,
that's how I think about marketing.
Google didn't exist for most of this room
when we started our careers.
The internet didn't exist
for most of the people
in this room so I've lived
a life where everything
was a fad, not just Snapchat,
the whole fucking internet
was a fad when I started my
career and so what's fascinating
to me is the next bet I
made was Google AdWords.
Google AdWords had come out
and for five cents a click
before they raised the
minimum to 10 cents,
I was buying up every wine
term and I was able to buy
words like wine and cabernet
and champagne for five
and 10 cents a click and
very honestly it is one
of the best things I ever did in my career
and it is no question
one of the worst things
I ever did in my career.
I bet very big and it worked very great
but I was young and I
was doing everything,
direct mail, print, radio, television.
I was branding, I was
marketing but I underspent
on Google AdWords.
I had, I always like to say,
I had the best hand in poker
and I didn't go all in.
It was working but I didn't
understand at that point
in my career how much it
was working and when I hear
like somebody introduced me and say,
from three to 60 million
dollars and it's impressive
and I'm glad and I love
it and it's my family,
it matters to me, but
every time I hear it,
I say to myself, it should have been 200.
And I'll tell you, it's why
I stand here in front of you
and I want to use that as a segue to why,
and the light is powerful
but I want to see your faces,
I need everybody to understand this,
I don't care if you're
selling to 17 farmers
a one million dollar aggregation system
in a B to B environment,
every person in this
room has to understand
how unbelievably under priced
and how unbelievably powerful
Facebook advertising is right now.
Right this second, the
scalable, under priced attention
in our society, and by the
way, if you were doing business
in the Nordics, it's an
even better deal than it is
in the U.S. because it's a
marketplace and it only reacts,
I love you guys for that, it
only reacts to how much money
you guys pump into the system.
When BMW and Sass and
Coca Cola actually wake up
and understand how under
priced Facebook's ads are,
the price of Facebook
ads is going to skyrocket
and you will regret, like
I do, in not spending money
in it today.
There is an unbelievable
amount of people in this room
who have opinions on how
Facebook works for their business
without ever running a Facebook ad.
We are making headline reading
and emotional decisions
about the current state of
marketing and opportunity.
We are not relying
enough on practitioners.
I have watched people buy
100 million dollar contracts
from one Facebook ad.
I've seen it.
Not I guessed it, I heard about it.
We work with the GEs and the
SAPs and the biggest brands
in the world.
We are grossly underestimating.
It's amazing to me that people
sit around and talk about
Trump and Brexit and Arab
Spring and these macro,
unbelievable, historic
cultural shifts in our society
and then an hour later
when they talk about
their little business,
their 100 million dollar,
500 million dollar, one billion dollar,
10 billion dollar little business
and they don't think
Facebook can affect it.
It is unbelievable naivety
and that's at best.
At worst, you are being grossly negligent
in how you're running your
business out of the laziness
to not become educated on
what is actually happening
in our game.
So, I'm fascinated by this.
I think this is the great opportunity.
This is a generational situation.
If you look at the history
of marketing, television,
radio, the internet, now
the social layer on top
of the internet, every
time there is a huge shift
of attention somewhere new,
enormous wealth is made
and enormous wealth is lost.
And this, my friends, is
the biggest of them all.
The amount of attention
shifting is extraordinary.
But I want you to hear something.
I do not believe that this
is about traditional media
versus digital media.
For example, one of the great
wastes of money in the world
is buying programmatic
banner ads and pre-rolls
across the web for five dollar
CPMs because it's cheap.
I also believe in America, for example,
that the Super Bowl ad that
costs 5.5 million dollars
for 30 seconds is by far
the best deal in marketing
because everybody in America will see it
and you get unbelievable awareness.
So for me, I'm fascinated by the nuances.
I think you can waste all
your money on Facebook
if you don't know how to use it.
As a matter of fact,
what's the ROI of a piano?
What's the ROI of a piano?
Let me help you.
For Gary Vaynerchuk (clucks tongue) zero.
I can't play for shit.
But for Billy Joel and Elton John,
the ROI was of billions of dollars.
The ROI of a basketball is zero for me,
for Lebron, a billion.
This is not about does this stuff work,
this is about do you
know what to do with it.
And the reality is, you don't
The far majority of people
in here have never been
practitioners of the
modern day story telling
and media planning and
execution for a business result
and that is where the opportunity is.
I'm fascinated by how
big this actually is.
I laugh when people don't
understand how much change
is happening and so this
rant, this passion I start
this keynote with is very simple.
It is my hope that one,
one, one person in this room
decides to go back home and
run their business properly
and it's not very complicated.
It's about becoming educated.
Education matters.
Just the education of the
day always matters more.
The fact that so many of
you have not spent 30 hours,
which is a lot but very
little based on the ambitions
that you have for yourself
or your organizations,
that you've not spent the 30
hours to either read on Google
or watch videos on YouTube to
how to run an Instagram ad,
how to place a Snapchat filter,
how to plan Facebook media
and you think that even if you've done it
you've outsourced it to a
25 year old who gets it,
is fascinating to me.
Who is the biggest advertiser on Google
in the first six years of Google?
Amazon.
Amazon was the biggest
advertiser on Google
in the first six years of Google AdWords.
It is not a coincidence that
Amazon is one of the biggest
companies in the world.
They used the under priced
attention to build their company.
Who was the biggest
advertiser of television
in the prime of the 1970's
and 80's when television
was at scale and under priced?
Proctor and Gamble.
It is not a coincidence that Tide and Dove
and Proctor and Gamble became
the biggest consumer packaged
goods products in the world.
This is very basic.
What were the biggest sports
in America in the 1940's
and 50's?
Baseball, horse racing, and boxing.
Who also spent the most time
distributing content on radio?
What was the biggest sports in
the last 20 years in America?
The NFL.
The biggest spender, the
biggest executor of content
in the medium.
The sport matched the content.
There's two young men
right there doing tricks
with soccer balls on
Instagram and YouTube.
It's because that content
and that formula works
on that platform and they
didn't have to get signed
by somebody to be able
to make that content.
They just went direct to the consumer
and then Adidas, the
biggest brand in the world
in that sport comes to them
and wants to do business with them.
I am fascinated by the
naivety slash audacity
of the 99% of people in
the business world today
and their disrespect for social media.
Why don't I help you guys?
Let me help you with something.
The word social media is the problem.
You know that, right?
The problem here is a branding problem.
Social media has a branding problem.
When I say the word social
media, for a lot of executives
in this room, especially
you B to B people,
that is a nuance.
That is a sprinkle.
That is a nice to have.
That is a it's gonna be here one day
but doesn't matter to me.
When I hear the word social
media, I think very simply,
I think this is the remote
control of our society
and I know that 50% of every
minute spent by human beings
on earth, zero to 100 years old,
is spent on a social media site.
50%.
I hear social media, my
brain says, the current state
of the internet.
And I have a funny feeling that
you would have a harder time
betting against the current
state of the internet
for your business than social media.
So now I implore you and my hope and dream
is that this audience
starts to think about this
just a little bit differently,
not because I'm passionate
and I'm going hard but
because there are truths
in what I'm saying and you
know them and you feel them
and you also know that
you can't call the bluff
one way or the other.
Meaning, I'm a big fan of AB testing.
If you believe that
your print, your radio,
your Google ads, your
sponsorships, your booths at events
are better than producing
videos that people
actually want to watch on
Facebook and then retargeting them
and putting 'em into a sales
funnel and then closing them,
well then you should test them.
To me, the fascination
is how anybody in 2018
is not testing at scale these phenomenons.
And so, I'm trying to put
pressure on the collective system
really, to be very frank
and I hope everybody
understands this, none
of you are my clients.
You guys aren't my brothers and sisters.
I'm about to leave Stockholm
very soon and go back
to New York.
I don't give a shit if you do
anything I'm talking about.
I really don't.
There's really only two
agendas I have here.
Number one, Tyler's filming
it and in four years
when CPM costs on Facebook
are 30 and 40 dollars,
I'm just gonna post a
video clip of this moment
and it's gonna say, I told you so.
(audience laughing)
Number two, which has been
much more fruitful for me,
is that when I do this
and I talk this way,
which is practical, not
emphatic, not passionate.
Practical.
I'm talking about what's
actually happening now
and everybody's acting and
executing and spending money
and energy like seven years ago.
This is not futuristic talk.
This is today.
I can talk to you about virtual reality
and AR machine learning
and voice all day long.
That's not practical for anybody in here.
But selling a contract
in a construction company
on Facebook which seems extremely
foreign to the collective
is happening every day for
the two or three practitioners
of this skill in that
platform and it's converting
a hell of a lot better
than your direct mail
and all the other shit
you're spending money
and energy on.
Period.
But you don't know that
because you haven't tested it.
I have.
I run direct mail and
Facebook for Wine Library.
I run direct mail and Facebook
for all my Sass products
that I'm an investor in.
I look at this stuff
everyday and so I say this
to have it on the record and number two,
it is an amazing feeling.
When I fly home I will
get an email that says,
four and a half years
ago I was in Alabama,
I heard your talk and I
own this and I did this
and here's my business now.
I'm looking to get my high
from an email that says,
you came to Stockholm in late 2017.
I didn't even know who you
were when you went on stage
but you yelled at me so
aggressively I said, fuck it,
I'll try it.
(audience laughing)
And then this happened.
And so that's where I'm at mentally.
I'm excited.
I think the thing that
you have to hear from me
is a couple more things
before we get into Q and A
and please, are we using the app here?
I assume we are.
So please, if you've got,
what I would implore right now
and then I'll go into the rest of my talk,
is if you have a basic,
social media, digital media,
marketing, branding
101 question, to ask it
because this is the environment to do it.
Right?
Because you can see this
theoretical talk on YouTube.
We're here together now so if you have
a very direct question.
I am a lawyer, how the hell
do I use Facebook to get more,
like, please ask right now.
Take out your app and
start asking questions
while I keep going
because the Q and A part
that's coming soon is the part.
Here's the part that's tricky.
I'm right on the framework
of where the attention is.
The problem is is if you
go home and spend $5,000
on Facebook ads, the
creative is the variable
of your success.
The picture, the video, the
words you write in that post
are the difference between
zero sales and 1,000 sales.
Zero dollars in donations
and a million dollars
in donations.
My vulnerability, my
kryptonite to my thesis
is the creative.
I have your attention right now.
This would be no different
than Facebook, right?
This framework of the
event we're in right now,
I have your attention.
This is a talk.
You came to listen.
You're here.
You're all paying attention-ish.
I see a couple of you on your phone.
Keep doing your thing,
it's more important.
But, if the content of
my speech is not good
and not interesting, I've
wasted my opportunity
with my creative to create the
event that I'm looking for.
Right?
So the thing that I'm
very passionate about is
please understand what
is actually happening
in this device and
here's what's happening.
This is a place where
math and data and science
mash into art and creativity
and equally, both of them,
have to be respected.
The short term financial
businesses running in here
care about math too much.
The overally long term and
ideological and artistic
people in this room
are going too over here
and not practical about the math.
The balance of the two is everything
and the platform of Facebook
and likes and these are
stream mentality sites that
have our attention right now,
Instagram and things of that nature,
is incredibly important to respect both.
For example, talking
about stream dynamics,
Twitter because of the
nature of the context
is over priced ads because
the ad prices have a floor
and they're not converting
as well and the attention
on Twitter is very different
than it is on Facebook
and Instagram thus making
the inventory over priced,
in my opinion as we sit here today.
So, the creative that you
put in Twitter matters just
as much every where else but
if you're paying too much
to get in front of somebody,
it's not going to be as valuable.
This is basic supply
and demand of attention
and then framed on top
of it, do you understand
the context of the creative
you have to put into it.
Now let me go a little 201 on this.
It's super important
for you to do one thing.
It's important for you to do what I did
before I took this stage
which is reverse engineer
the audience.
The number one mistake everybody's making
on social media content
right now is they're using
the same content and they're spreading it
throughout all the
platforms and they're using
socialist distribution
not as a native place
to story tell.
Let me explain.
All of you sitting here,
how many people here
consume content on more
than one social network?
Raise your hand.
Fantastic.
A majority of this room.
So you're gonna understand
this and this is fascinating
and after I tell you
this, I can't wait for you
to spend the next day or two
realizing how interesting
this nuance is.
I am me.
I'm Gary, right?
When I go into Instagram,
my psychology is different
than when I go into Twitter.
My psychology is different
than when I go into Facebook.
Every one of you uses these
platforms differently.
When you're on LinkedIn,
that's an amazing ring.
When I go, that's really funny.
When I go into Instagram,
my mindset is younger.
It's swaggier.
It is just different.
There's a youthfulness.
There's a pulse.
There's a cultural
aspect that even the copy
that I write with my two
thumbs is different slang
than what I would write on LinkedIn,
than what I would write on Twitter,
than what I would write on Facebook.
Understand that when you
put a picture or words
or video on one of these
platforms, the person
you're trying to reach,
even though you targeted ads
across all of them for
44 to 45 year old women
with two children and
$100,000 income, even though
she's the same person,
her mindset is different
in every platform and
that context, that nuance
is imperative.
You also have to respect the platform.
Instagram is a platform
that only allows you, today,
to make a video that is
only one minute long.
That is a different
story telling restriction
than if you're making a
four and a half minute video
on Facebook.
Too many companies that
are advanced in here
will make one video and then edit it down
for the one minute version by
their best half assed efforts
from the four minute version
that they put on Facebook
without creating narratively
for that platform
or deeply understanding
how, what I would call,
DJ the content into the platform.
If you're into music, then
you realize over the last
20 years, we've seen the
growth of DJ culture.
It is a different skillset
than being the person
that creates the original song.
If you become great at
being a DJ off of a piece
of a content to the six
or seven logos that matter
at the bottom of my screen down here,
if you can become a great
DJ, if you can take a piece
of content, if you can
understand what you want to say,
what message are you trying
to make me understand,
use my dentist service.
Buy my Sass product.
Use my bank.
Hire my law firm.
Work with me, donate for
me, vote for me, buy me,
donate for me.
If you understand what you
are trying to get across
and you understand that
it's words, audio, and video
in the way we've communicated
for the last 100 plus years,
and you understand how to
respect and I mean really respect
this and this and this and that and that
and understand how they're
different, how they work,
inside out, spend the 30 to
40 hours to become educated
on how they work and then
actually with your own fingers
place it, run it, and watch
it, and do that for the next
six months, you have a
shot to be successful
and if you do not, you
can still be successful
but you're doing it at your own peril.
Every day goes by, this
is grabbing attention.
Now, you may not like that.
You might be very upset that
the kids are on their phone
the whole time but you
have to make me a promise.
You have to leave your opinions
about technology at the door
when you walk into the
office and run your business
because your romance is gonna
put you out of business.
And, I want to debate you on your romance.
When you go to a restaurant
and you see a couple
sitting there and both
of them are on the phone
and not talking, you love
to nudge your partner
and say, isn't that sad?
That's terrible.
Right?
Oh look at this, that's terrible.
I look at it very differently.
When I walk into a
restaurant and I see a couple
sitting there and both
of them are on the phone
the whole 30 times, I get excited.
I feel better for them.
I'm happy for them.
Let me tell you why.
I'm serious, my man.
It's very simple.
30 years ago that same couple
sitting at that restaurant,
they didn't talk to each other.
They sat across from each other,
all of you have seen this,
all of you, I'm looking
around the crowd, you know,
this is not 14 year
old girls in the crowd.
We're a little older here.
How many people over 35?
Raise your hand.
Perfect.
(audience laughing)
All of you have seen
what I saw 15 years ago
which is you went to a
restaurant and you just happened
to notice while you were
doing your thing, two people
sitting there, a couple
not saying a fucking word
to each other.
Right?
My friends, technology has not changed us.
Technology has exposed us.
The reason those two
people are sitting there
and both on the phone is because
they don't like each other
and when I see two people
sitting there in their 40's,
50's, 60's, 70's and 80's
normally both on the phone
and not talking to each
other, I see it as a mitzvah.
I'm happy for them because
20 years ago they had nothing
to do and they had to
get through that hour
hating each other not
saying a fucking word
but now they can look at their
YouTube video and be happy.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
It's true.
Things are changing.
You have to understand your culture.
I'm awfully aware of the
different nuances of the culture
of the Nordics versus the U.S.
When I speak everyone's, and
I'm type A for even America.
People are like we're different here.
We're subtle.
I understand.
I'm not asking you to do
anything uncomfortable.
I'm asking you to communicate
and not waste your money.
It's not ground breaking.
It's not revolutionary.
It's a bad idea to waste
money and just because
your organization scores
it that way or your boss
believes in that doesn't mean it's right
and so we are living through
a very big culture change.
The culture change is phenomenal.
This is all time change.
15 years ago if you went
on the internet to go on
a dating site and went on
a date, you were weird.
Now that is the norm.
Can you imagine if I told
the parents in this room
20 years ago that I'm from the future
and let me tell you what's
gonna happen in 20 years,
you're gonna rather your
14 year old girl go into
a stranger's car every
day to get around the town
then to drive herself because
you would think that's safer.
Nobody would've bought
me selling them Uber.
Nobody would've bought 20
years ago that kids would be
going into strangers, you were taught,
how many people over 35?
We were taught you don't
go into strangers' cars
at all costs.
Now we're paying a fucking
premium to go inside of them.
The culture has changed.
It's not changing, it's not coming.
There are 60 year old men in
here who texted a poop emoji
to their friend last night.
(audience laughing)
The same 60 year old executive who said,
what's an emoji 18 months ago.
The same 60 year old
executive who 10 years ago
said they would never be on Facebook.
The same 60 year old executive
for 15 years ago said to me,
I'm not getting a cellphone.
My pager works just fine.
We, as a culture, do not like change.
And in that we lose.
It is time for you to go on
the offense, not the defense
because I have a funny thing
to tell you about technology.
Everything I believe in
didn't exist 15 years ago.
Not the smart phone, not
YouTube, not Facebook,
not apps, nothing.
Did not exist.
And if you think the last
15 years have been crazy,
wait till you see what
technology is gonna do
in the next 15 years.
This is nothing.
You know what this is?
This iPhone X, you know what this is?
This is a pager.
And in 10 years this is
gonna look so archaic,
we're not gonna know what
to do with ourselves.
So, let me ask you a question.
How many people in this
room right now are retiring
in the next 10 years?
And I don't mean you're gonna
crush it and sell your company
for a billion dollars
and live on an island.
I mean, you're old and you're finished.
(audience laughing)
Raise your hand, 10 years, show me.
Okay, great, great.
So for the 13 of you,
you can take this with somewhat importance
but for the rest of you, my friends,
you have to understand
what we're living through.
We're living through a race.
We're about to run a
marathon in technology.
Technology will eat up
every aspect of everything
always and forever.
It's how it works.
The book stores were first.
Then it was people that
owned taxi services.
Then it was the hotel industry with Airbnb
but it will keep going.
The biggest TV networks in the world,
now that they're so TT, this
will keep going, everything.
Just because you have big contracts
with the biggest companies in the world,
what's that contract worth
when that company is not alive?
This is real and so we're
about to run a marathon
and the reason I stress
on you to be good at that
is not because I think
that's the end all, be all
but you have no chance
to be good at AR and VR
and machine learning and crypto
currency and everything else
that's coming next if you did
not ground yourself in this.
You can't run a 40 mile
marathon right now on the spot
if you haven't been on the
treadmill for the last six months
and running little mini races to prepare
and if you are not adapting
this psychology first,
religion first, and then
becoming a practitioner,
you need to be the architect,
the general contractor,
and the plumber because if
you don't, you will lose
and so I implore you while
it's easy, it's fucking easy,
to learn this.
While it's easy you better
get serious about this
because the next wave of
technology is gonna gobble you up
and I implore you to take this
speech very, very seriously.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Moderator] Gary Vee!
I think, should I stand there or here?
- You can do anything you want.
- Can I come close to you?
- Yes, let's get real close.
- Okay.
Thank you, that was great
and we all feel like dinosaurs now.
How many feel like a dinosaur now?
Yes, quite a few.
- Can I say something?
That was actually, thank you.
One more time, dinosaur.
Who feels like a dinosaur?
You know what's amazing about this game?
Literally in 60 days you don't have to.
What I love about this
game is you could be
a dinosaur of everything but good news,
that already happened.
This is one of the most liberating things
I could tell somebody and by the way,
I'm not saying to make you feel good
because I think you can
tell, I don't give a shit.
(audience laughing)
I'm saying it because it's true.
The fact that you can go
from a zero, a dinosaur,
I don't know what the
hell he's talking about
or more importantly I understand
but I know nothing about
it, in 60 days and 40 hours,
you can know everything.
That's incredible.
Free information.
Who's over 35?
Raise your hand real quick.
Tell these kids about
something called the library.
Like we used to go somewhere
to get information.
What do you want to know?
In our fingers, in a second.
So, what excites me is, sure
you could feel like a dinosaur,
sure, it might feel intense
but I see it as optimism,
not negativity.
This is an opportunity for all of you
and the biggest thing is,
you're gonna live much longer
than you think.
There's a lot of people here
in their 40's, 50's, and 60's
who think they're wrapping
up and finishing it
and it was past where all
the opportunity for happiness
professionally is the next
30 years between 50 and 80
'cause you can start your own
business around your passion,
around ice hockey or beverages
or soup or suits or sneakers.
This is so big that I just
think people are underestimating
how great it can be.
- Thank you.
We feel much better.
(man laughing)
(audience laughing)
I actually do.
That's good.
Keep the questions coming in.
You heard Gary, this
is a free consultation
so just use the time.
And, I have a question here from Mark.
What about ads on Facebook
for non-profit organizations?
Does it work?
How should it be done?
- I was among a well
member for an organization
called Charity Water that
I'd love for all of you
to look at because it's
run by a club promoter
and an entrepreneur which is
why it's being successful.
Right?
We're doing very well.
We're really trying to bring fresh water
to the entire world.
Scott Harrison is an all time
great non-profit executive.
In the presentation on Sunday
night, which was remarkable,
the biggest growth for the
company has been getting
five dollar return on investment
for every dollar spent
on Facebook.
My friends, listen, it's
under priced attention.
It's six dollar CPM and
you can target 44 year old
Korean women who like hockey.
I mean, it's crazy.
Do you understand?
It's crazy what it can do.
It's why it's changing our
macro, geopolitical climate.
It's going to be 45 dollar
CPM in about three years.
That's it.
It's just a lot better to
pay six dollars instead of 45
especially when you have to
spend hundreds of thousands
and millions.
So yes, it can work for non profits.
- Another question.
How do you think your
strategy regarding visibility
and marketing on Instagram
and Snapchat would work if,
this is hypothetical or not, I don't know,
I am CMO of Patek Phillip OMS.
Many people in marketing
would say that it's proven
that luxury brands lose
brand value and positioning
if they're visible in the wrong context
with the math brands.
- I think there's a lot of things in there
in that statement.
I would say, number one,
ego is mixed in there.
I would say naivety is mixed there.
Those two are the things that stand out.
I'm empathetic.
I'm empathetic to why Rolex
or Cartier or Aston Martin
may think that this is below them.
It's also why Tiffany's
and Aston Martin and Rolex
will go out of business
over the next decade.
Let me say it very clear one more time.
Go out of business in the
next decade or 15 years
if they don't act.
They will because every day that goes,
let me tell you something
about social media
and luxury brands.
None of them were there eight years ago.
They're all there now,
they're just half pregnant
because they're fucking
snobs run by snobs.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
And you know what's
amazing about meritocracy
and capitalism and open
market dynamics, snobs die.
- This is not a, just
personal opinion based on
where you come from?
No, yeah?
- No I mean look, listen,
I don't think I can win
if I have personal opinions.
Christie's is selling $800,000
products on Instagram.
Is that a good enough answer?
What do you want?
Like, do you not understand
how society works?
Do you not understand that
every rich person 35 to 45
only lives on Instagram
and doesn't even know
what the fuck Vogue is?
Like, do you live in the world?
(audience laughing)
No, but I'm being real.
Listen, this is an opportunity like
are people that tone deaf or
is it that you're not doing it
because inside the companies
of these luxury brands
they don't have an internal
MMM that knows how to score
the metrics of the new modern
platforms so they over value
the impressions of print,
oh by the way for anybody
that's not in the business,
the way that print is valued
on how many people see it
is they give eight times
circulation value to how many
of the magazines are printed.
So if a high net worth
brand where you're in with
high net worth brands prints
500,000 or 100,000 copies,
they give you the fact that
800,000 people will see your ad
on page 237 of that
magazine because you know
everybody takes the Robb
Report and Vogue and GQ
and leaves it on a plane and
then somebody else gets there,
picks it up and opens it and
carefully goes to page 237
and consumes your ad.
So listen, I think, to
answer your question,
my personal experience,
no, I think it's their
personal experience of how they
grew up or more importantly
how they wish it would be
because a lot of people
that work at brands like
that like the inclusive
on a pedestal nature of that job.
Oh, and by the way, I don't blame you.
Enjoy it while it lasts.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
- Okay, we have a quite a
few questions that ask about
what is the, like after
Facebook when that becomes
too expensive, what's the next thing?
- I don't know if you guys
know but I'm not Nostradamus.
(audience laughing)
I have no idea and that's the beauty
of day trading attention and
trying not to have opinions.
I don't know.
I don't know if AR will
be here fast enough
that there's something
that gets brought up.
I don't know how soon we're
gonna wear contact lenses
and live in a virtual reality
world, not in the real world.
I don't know.
What I know is that I have
a mental mindset, a religion
to know what it is.
I, in 1996 would stand up
here and tell you about email.
I, in 2001 would tell you about Google.
I, in 2004 would tell you
about programmatic banners
and YouTube.
I, in 2007 would tell you about Twitter.
Like, I don't know at all.
I know that what got me
here isn't gonna get me
to the next place and
I know that the market,
much like luxury brands,
doesn't care about little old me
so when it's here in four years,
I'm gonna do a lot of work
and stay up late and educate
myself and use my intuition
and my skill of consumer
behavior to figure out
how to story tell in the
place that has now emerged.
- [Moderator] Okay and so
then you have to go out
for the knowledge so your
intuition will work the right way.
Where do you sort of go?
- Everywhere where we are currently.
So I will tell you the pulse
of culture, no question,
lives on Instagram.
You should spend an hour a
day just searching Instagram
hash tags and following a lot of people
and then reading what people
leave, you should spend,
let me rephrase.
If you're a strategist, a
psychologist, somebody who,
anthropologist, if you're
curious about culture,
it is playing out in
your eyes on Instagram.
It is the pulse, the heartbeats
of the emerging cultures.
I knew that eight year old
girls were gonna make slime
two years ago.
It's right there.
- Couldn't you have stopped it?
(audience laughing)
- I could have.
(audience clapping)
But that wouldn't have
allowed me to invest
a lot of money into the
Elmer's glue company.
(audience laughing)
- [Moderator] You did?
- I sure did.
And, if I took my coin base out right now,
not that I'm a genius and I
surely didn't bet enough money
but if I take my coin base
account out right now,
I just want to be very accurate
so there's no confusion,
by paying attention to culture
and betting on people's
kind of actions I bought
on, let's see here,
on February 18, 2014,
I bought my bit coin.
Not last week.
What happens when you
stay curious and humble
is you start listening.
When you start listening
and executing it allows you
to have the audacity to start talking.
That is a good strategy.
- [Moderator] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Yes.
This one.
How important is personal brand compared
to the company brand as an entrepreneur?
- Look, I think everybody
has different levers.
If you're highly charismatic
and extremely handsome,
you should build a personal brand.
I think if you're an introvert
and you don't like people,
you shouldn't.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
It's true.
Look, it's very true.
There are an amazing
amount of people building
incredible businesses,
organizations, governments,
non profits, and businesses
that you'll never hear of.
They're more comfortable behind the scenes
and that's incredible.
Not everybody should be out
there doing, you have to,
self awareness is the magic.
Knowing who you are is the magic.
Not being on stage and
making a joke, right?
So, I think it's incredible
if you're good at it
and you like it and you like people
and you can take the heat.
The key to a personal brand is humility.
Like, when I put out content,
there's a lot of comments
that I'm a jackass or
I'm too cocky or I suck.
If you can't quantify
that, you won't produce
so you have to know who
you are, if you're doing it
for the right reasons, and
you have to deploy empathy
to why your personality
may not work for somebody
because everybody's got an
opinion and they're allowed
to share it.
- Do you see any danger in
the social media bubble?
Are we getting more stupid
by being fed with news
that confirm what we
already know or think?
- [Gary] No, I think we've
been historically stupid.
(laughing)
- That's very true.
- Here's a very simple question.
Life is binary.
When we have this conversation
about social media
manipulating us, life's binary.
I'm gonna ask you very simple.
Would you rather have the
society that we live in
be in a place where
they can consume content
from lots and lots of voices
or did you like 1973 better
when two or three or one old
white dude could tell you
what to think?
(audience laughing)
You can't have both.
I mean that.
Like, all of a sudden,
traditional media's been this
incredible golden era for all
the people that are scared
by the new regime.
Really?
You liked when two people
controlled the media?
I'm thrilled all these men are being outed
for their transgressions.
That happens when the world's open,
not when they're friends with the people
that control the media.
Your choice.
- But I think most people
would agree that, yes,
it's better now in many
ways but still we have
Mr. Putin and we have other
realities that really are
affecting democracy and what about that?
Are we supposed to--
- Dictators get to play too.
(audience laughing)
You know, yes.
The naivety of the human
race that everything's
gonna stay the same, everything
is gonna ebb and flow
and everything will always ebb and flow.
I just am an unbelievable buyer of us.
I'm an optimist of us.
We've been around a long time.
We have figured this out.
It always gets better.
You may not like it.
There might be something you don't like
but it always gets better.
You know what's scarier than social media?
The black plague.
(audience laughing)
I just believe in us.
Like, they'll always ebb and flow.
I mean, Putin is executing
my thesis which is the media
controls thinking and he
can use the tools as much
as anybody else but this
is where I get really mad
at human beings, we love
to blame somebody else.
Vladimir Putin did not come
to my house and make me
read the propaganda.
You read it.
You're a big girl, you're a big boy,
stop pointing fingers.
Social and digital and the
new way communication works
is exposing us.
It's not changing us.
You know how the Facebook algorithm works?
If you keep clicking
and reading that stuff,
it will show you more.
You want to try an incredible,
actually you know what,
I've never done this.
You want to try an incredible experiment?
Go to Facebook.
How many people use Facebook?
Raise your hand.
Great.
Go to Facebook and search at
the top, which people don't do,
search at the top a subject that you like.
Something you like.
Hockey, peanut butter and jelly, E sports,
whatever you want.
Shoes, suits, parenting,
something you like.
Search it then what shows
up like all the posts.
Like 'em all.
Like them all.
(audience laughing)
And read three of them.
Stay in the screen and read three of them
and then tell me what your
newsfeed does the next month.
Tell me how much the bad
guys are manipulating you.
You're manipulating yourself.
You don't want to own up to it.
- But okay, let's have a real,
or might be a real example.
(audience clapping)
Trump says, we don't want any
immigrants in this country,
especially not the ones
from Belarus, okay?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And every argument
for the immigrants being
in the United States
won't reach peoples' feeds
so this is the reality and
they want to throw you out
of the country.
How do you go about to sort
of to get into this space,
to reach these people?
- So there's a lot of questions in that.
First of all, Facebook
has a lot of attention
but it doesn't control all the air waves.
It doesn't control all the communication.
There's nobody who's
doing anything in a macro
that people aren't aware of.
It's not like people spend 100%
of their time in their feed.
Let me tell you something,
in America, if you only watch
Fox News or if you only
watch CNN, you're seeing
two different things too.
There's no difference
of your Facebook feed
than if you have Fox News on the whole day
or CNN on the whole day.
We are manipulating
our consumption always.
Also, in that scenario, I
know how to get to Americans
to know about the Bela-Russian
thing just as well
as the Trump or the Hillary
Clinton or Obama machine
and believe it or not, on
Facebook, I have a fair chance.
In old media, I don't.
- Okay, let's argue about that later.
- That's nothing to argue about.
(woman laughing)
You will be historically wrong
if you believe what I just,
one more time.
Trump 40 years ago says
we're kicking everybody out.
His two best friends are
Rupert and Les Moonves
and he controls the air waves,
you know, like dictatorships.
This is historical.
This is not my opinion.
Fidel Castro did it.
This is simple.
Do you want two or three people
controlling the information
or do you want an open marketplace?
There's nothing to argue about.
The conversation that we
need to have is our lack
of accountability of what we
consume and our curiosity.
The day after 9/11, I started
going to Al Jazeera's website
for the next year because
I wanted to learn.
That is way more important.
That is what we need to be as
a, we need to be empathetic
and we need to hear other points of view.
Whether you consume that on
Facebook or on television
or the newspaper or the
magazine, that's a human thing,
not a media distribution argument.
- Don't blame the
platform, okay, we get it.
- Do you agree?
- I do agree, yes, I do.
(audience laughing)
(laughing)
Okay, someone wants to know
if you ever were wrong.
(audience laughing)
- A ton.
And let me tell you something
and this will make sense
and I think, Babin, this has
been the theme of our like
trip on this, I bought crypto in 2014.
Not the earliest, I had
friends buying it in 11 and 12
but definitely not the latest.
I have a lot of wins on my
board in early investing.
The reason somebody would ask
that question is I only talk
about things I know, not things I think.
I'm very basic.
I talk very little, very, I mean,
just in a very narrow place.
I could talk to you today
about AR and crypto currency
and the internet of things,
I just know there's a lot
of people that are smarter
and better to talk about it
than me.
So the reason I feel like
cocky or are you ever wrong
is I stay so God damn narrow
and I talk about things
that have already happened.
I'm not guessing up here my friends.
I'm just social commentating
on what happened
and that's it.
And so, yeah, I'm wrong every day.
I just don't think it's a
good strategy to go on stage
(audience laughing)
and guess or opinionate.
- [Moderator] Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
(audience clapping)
- Okay, this one.
How do you use Facebook
in order to raise capital
for a start up?
- You run ads against employees
of venture capitalists.
(audience laughing)
- Is that a good answer,
whoever asked the question?
- What's really interesting
about that is how great this is.
The fact that I can make a
video on my phone for free,
articulate my points of
view of why my start up
and I as a founder are
special and then spend $600
reaching every single
employee of every single
venture capital firm that
could potentially want
to talk to me is the greatest
opportunity in the history
of marketing and communications.
That's how you use
Facebook to get in front.
Now, if you're not a
practitioner and you just talk
about Facebook but you don't
know anything about it,
you might not know that one
of the ways you can run ads
on Facebook is clicking
a button that says,
go to these company employees in the feed.
You may not know that.
That's it.
Headline readers, practitioners.
My plea here today is for
you to become a practitioner.
If you're the CEO and 90
years old or 22 years old
and you're gonna change the
world and everybody in between,
you have to be the practitioner.
This is oxygen now.
You can't have this as a nice to have.
Communication in today's
world is the value
and you have to be good at it.
- Gary, what's your best
tip on delivering quality
at scale?
- Driving down the cost of
the production of the content.
The biggest reason so
many people are losing
is 'cause they work with
agencies or internal people
that aren't producing enough
at an efficient enough price.
The reason, for the hands
that went up that follow me,
the reason I started
talking about documenting
versus creating is because
I'm trying to produce
so much content, having
a man following me around
with a camera, though
narcissistic and crazy,
has allowed me to create so
much content because so much
is happening all the time
and then I'm DJing it.
I think the biggest reason
people are struggling
is everything is too perfect,
too fancy and too subjective.
I let the market decide.
I deploy humility with my content.
I produce it, I put it out there,
and then I watch what happens.
Not before.
And so, this camera is so
much better of a camera
than what we had just six
years ago that costs thousands
of dollars.
You don't need unbelievable equipment.
You need people who are native
to today's digital world
to produce content.
I would also say you have to
use content in multiple ways.
When I make a video, I
turn that into audio.
I turn that into the written word.
I get to write a 500 word
essay on LinkedIn off of
maybe an answer that
I just gave here today
because it was recorded.
Then it's transcribed.
Create a framework that
creates enough quality content
at scale so you get a
thousand at bats instead of 13
which then allows you
to not debate quality.
Quality is subjective, period.
Until it hits the market and
there's too much audacity
and ego in the executives in this room
and in my own company of what quality is
before it goes out and I fight
that, I fight that daily.
- Okay.
But what homework can you
do earlier on in the process
to ensure that this
documenting or this produce
of content has a good quality?
I mean, working with your values--
- I think the way you do it
you start and you put it out
and then you learn from the
feedback which then informs you
on the next thing that you do.
It's iteration.
It's the reps.
You gotta do it.
You can't read or debate about push ups.
If you want the ROI of push ups,
you've gotta do the fucking push ups
and that's how I think about content.
I really do.
You can't read or debate
about the push ups
and I don't think you can read or debate,
now, I believe in strategy
and consumer insights.
I live on it.
You should do that but that has a moment
and then you need to produce and at scale
because there's a lot of
platforms and a lot of attention
and it's fragmented and you
gotta give yourself chances
and by putting out 800
videos, 30 of them are gonna
teach you so much for you to
be better at the next 800.
- So a major piece of
advice is just start?
- Yep.
(audience laughing)
- Okay.
- And that is very counter
cultural to organizations
and corporations.
They're in the business of not starting.
- This is just a question
from me because I know
one can order you as a speaker
with or without cursing.
Is this with or without cursing?
(audience laughing)
- I really hope this was with cursing.
- [Moderator] You're in Sweden.
I don't think anyone minds anyway.
- Love you guys, take care.
If you can't curse in
Stockholm, you might as well
close up shop.
You know?
Stockholm can handle it.
- What do you do when your
target audience is too small
for Facebook or LinkedIn advertising tools
to let your ads through?
- Got it.
So the segmentation you're
creating is too small?
Who asked that question?
Ma'am, when you go for your targeting,
it shows a not a significant enough?
So I think for now, because
Facebook is so under priced,
when I try to do that, think
about a very interesting
strategy that you might like.
If you're going that small,
you're trying to reach
decision makers, right?
Think a lot about the
people that influence
the decision maker.
The reason I love employees of as a target
is because you never know which
employee has the CEO's ear.
It's funny to me and in my company of 800
that there is 30, 40 people
that are very junior,
have a lot of influence over
me more than other people
that are very senior.
So, I think Facebook's so under
priced that you should just
add a wider range and give
away that money on the CPMs
because it's still worth
it to get to the group
that you're trying to reach.
So when I get too small,
I just make it wider
with age or preference or I'll tweak it.
Or by location because I know
that a lot of big companies
are there.
I widen it because I
still value it so much
that even wasting 80% of it
I still think is under priced
because the other option
is what's your alternative?
Right?
Sending them a direct
mail or cold emailing them
or sending them a message on
LinkedIn is not being heard.
Make sense-ish?
Do we have a mic?
I want to have this conversation.
Do we have one?
- Where's the microphone?
- Oh right, Jesus Christ, that's insane.
You were right there, love it.
- Wow.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] I guess it makes
sense but sometimes, you know,
you have the people you
work for, they don't want
to spend a lot of money.
- No shit.
(audience laughing)
It doesn't make it wrong, right?
- [Woman] No, no.
- Like, I get it.
Like I'm giving you the actual answer.
If you tell me I only get a $1,000 budget
because they don't believe in it
well that means you should
go find another job.
- [Woman] Okay.
- Good.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
And I mean that, you
should find another job
if you unbelievably believe
that what we believe in
is right.
If you don't, well then
you don't but, to me,
this is a real decade of
the haves and the have nots
and you need to be smart
because the opportunity is great
if you actually understand.
The fact that you have targeted a segment
that is not big enough means
that you're 99.7% ahead
of most of the marketers in the world.
You need to take advantage
of that, not just regress
into the machine.
- I wonder if her boss
is here or if he's here
or she if that's good or bad.
- I think it's good because I would hope
that she or he listens to
this conversation and says,
screw that guy on stage.
Here's a couple of more
dollars, let's prove him wrong
and then I hope that
she makes good content
so that we could prove him or her wrong.
- Okay, so these are good
arguments for getting
an organization going but
what else could you tell,
for example, Lars is 59 years old,
not very keen on spending
money on social media.
- Listen, I don't have a huge
passion that 59 year old Lars
spends money on social media.
I really don't.
A, I don't give a fuck about Lars
but B, B, the market will
be the decision maker.
I don't want people to pander
to me or to the history.
Like, I think Lars and Susan
should see what it's like
for themselves but if
they don't, you know,
much bigger companies than
yours have gone out of business.
Why?
Because of this argument.
Right?
If my argument was wrong
then IBM would have never let
Microsoft happen.
Then Microsoft would've
never let Google happen.
Google would've never let Facebook happen.
Companies are built when
people don't see things.
Or, they see them but
they don't make change
because the people in the
company don't actually care
about the health of the company.
They care about themselves.
(audience clapping)
Super not fun,
super not fun to make
the proper investment
into Facebook right now
if the head of marketing
is bonused on efficiency on
a thing that doesn't score
Facebook advertising.
(audience laughing)
- Okay, this is a personal question to you
from someone in the audience.
Have you negotiated a deal
with Apple to give you
six dollars per view on
iPhone you would've made
at least $50,000 by now.
I haven't.
Apple isn't super in the
business of negotiating
directly with me.
(audience laughing)
I haven't but what I would say is this.
I have zero expectations of
the other person or platform.
I think one of the biggest
mistakes is people spend
a lot of time here saying,
well Facebook is benefiting
from me or this or that.
I don't care.
When I go into business, whether
it's a human or a platform,
I try to figure out what
I'm trying to get out of it.
I always like if I'm getting
a little less out of it
because then I have leverage
and that's how I think about
the world and so I don't
think about what Google
and Apple and Facebook
are getting out of it.
I think about what I'm getting out of it
and if it's good enough for
me, then that's fine by me
and I think a lot of people
are misplaying their strategies
because of some theoretical
debate of who's getting
the better of the relationship.
I just try to spend time on
what I'm trying to get out
of the relationship and
if those two guys get 80%
of the value because they
get all my content for free
and it helps them and they
never buy a sneaker or a book
or anything, I don't care.
It makes me happy.
Fine.
It's not why I'm doing
it and I think people get
really caught up in the wrong psychology.
- Good.
With an increasing CPM on
Facebook is the Facebook stock
the best investment today?
- Listen, I think actions
are better than words.
I don't understand Wall
Street at all, period.
Let's start there.
I don't trust those fuckers.
(audience laughing)
There's only two stocks that I buy ever.
Like ever.
Facebook and Amazon.
Period.
That is the only stocks that I've bought
in the last five years
because of Mark and Jeff.
I believe companies are
complete replications
of the leadership and I
think both of those guys
are playing long term not
to make the stock good
in the next 90 days and
that's how you actually win
in business.
You invest in the next things and so, yes,
I think Facebook is grossly
under priced at $175.
Now, could macro economics
crash the world economy
and that 175 go to 85?
Of course but if you put,
well, if you put $175
into Facebook and you never
need that money, ever,
I am convinced blindly
that you will return
and investment on that in a 10 year macro
and that's how I think
about Amazon and Facebook.
- It's been really great
getting to know you today
and also yesterday in
Gothenburg but what will you do
in the next 15 years?
Do you have a plan or is it
just or what's your objectives?
- I don't know if you heard earlier
about the Nostradamus thing.
(woman laughing)
My intuition is, over
the last year or two,
I've become intoxicated
with impacting young men.
I have a lot of young guys following me
because of the alpha nature.
You can see, this is
probably the most alpha I am
because when I'm on stage
and nobody can talk back,
I like that.
Right?
(audience laughing)
And it allows me to be
a little more bravado
and I'm a little bit more of a showman.
When I'm one on one in
real life it comes down
in a different direction
but through my personality
I've gotten the attention
of a lot of young men
and I'm really trying to
teach gratitude and empathy
and kindness.
I think these are weapons
to why I've been successful
and I do have an ambition
over the next 15 years
to become unbelievably
popular to that demo
so that I can make them
a different version
than what they used to look
up to, Rolexes and Porsches
and parties and I do
have some pretty lofty
historical legacy ambitions
on my ability to communicate
and the way that my mother raised me.
My intuition is that
every day that goes by
that continues to pull at me more.
Yeah, I want to be historically correct.
- And that really comes
through when you spend time
with you and I was just wondering,
what did your mother do?
- She taught me, boy, she's fucking,
she did everything right.
So what did she do?
She over accentuated
when I did good things.
Meaning, I remember
clearly opening the door
for an elderly woman
when I was seven or eight
at McDonald's.
You know, we're just going.
I just remember this clearly.
I opened the door for this elderly woman.
My mom acted, at that moment,
like I won the Nobel Peace Prize.
So she was very aggressive
when I was being kind
or deploying empathy.
But she also didn't let
me get away with things.
So, she knew I was gonna
be successful long before
anybody else but when
I would get D's and F's
on my report card she would
punish me for a week or two
even though she knew it
meant nothing but she wanted
to teach me that things had repercussions.
She was my biggest cheerleader
but she was practical
and I'm so grateful for
her and so she built up
my self esteem to an
uncomfortably high level.
(audience laughing)
And she raised three children with no help
and worked her ass off.
Like, I can't even, she
did some things wrong
but it came out of what
she did amazingly well.
Like, I can't do anything for
myself like peel an orange
or wash clothes because my
mom did everything for me.
She was that hard core.
She created an incredible framework for me
and to be very honest with
you, so much of what I do
is out of guilt and
gratitude for how my parents
raised me and me not having
anything and having to work
for it that I'm trying to,
I feel like a lot of this
is me giving,
as lucrative as this is
for me to get paid for,
and I'm sure you guys and
the organizers for my fee,
but I'm very fortunate,
the companies I'm building,
my time allocation is
far greater for me to be
in the business than to
be here for a day but this
and knowing I was gifted
with a communication style
that is actually gonna
get three people here
to do something, that has
a lot to do with the way
I was parented.
I'm desperate to give back
the wisdom and the framework
that Sasha and Tamara gave to me.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you Gary, that's beautiful.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- And one last question was
from someone in the audience.
Can I get my selfie taken
with you and maybe they can
by the book table?
- 100%, let's go.
Oh at the book, oh that's a segue.
I wanted to do it here.
Sorry, don't want to break the system.
Yes, I will be at the book table.
I'm ready to go.
- [Moderator] Yeah.
- Do we want that one
person to come up here now?
- Yeah, who wrote that?
- Who wrote that?
(man speaking softly)
Let's go.
It's fucking selfie time.
(audience clapping)
Pleasure.
You ready?
- [Man] Yeah, sure.
(speaks a foreign language)
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
- [Moderator] Gary V, thank you.
Thank you guys.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
You were great.
You were so good.
- That was great.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
- Hope you guys liked it.
Two things, what did you
think of the key note
and number two, what's your
take on the Stockholm syndrome?
(upbeat rock music)